[Musique]
et avec nous pour ont parlé thomas
portement ont dû parlement de l'union
populaire bonsoir thomas porte merci
d'être avec nous vous connaissez bien ce
métier de cheminot on va en reparler
maxence briquet porte parole du parti à
la reconquête la reconquête d'eric
zemmour merci d'être avec nous également
les syndicats dont qu'ils réclament on
l'a entendu l'amélioration des
conditions de travail des des embauches
une prime qu'ovide on peut parler
réellement d'une dégradation des
conditions de travail accentuée par la
crise sanitaire également dans ce
secteur thomas porte qu'est ce qu'il y a
de pire dans ce secteur par rapport aux
autres mais il ya beaucoup de choses qui
se courait les c'est aussi pour ça qu'il
ya une colère sociale et la sncf parce
que ça fait des mois que la direction
refuse d'ouvrir des négociations
salariales de haut niveau et à la sncf
les salaires sont gelés depuis huit ans
donc huit années consécutives sans
augmentation de salaire alors que
l'inflation augmenté y compris même le
smic augmente et si on a calculé par
exemple la rémunération des dix plus
hauts dirigeants de la sncf en 2019
s'est quasiment trente mille euros par
mois soit neuf fois le salaire des
cheminots donc c'est absolument
scandaleux il ya eu des conditions de
travail dégradées puisqu'on a envoyé les
cheminots quand même travaillé pendant
le confinement pour assurer le service
public et c'est tout à fait normal mais
aujourd'hui ils demandent une
reconnaissance puisqu'ils ont été
travaillés au départ sans masque sanguin
c'était absolument dangereuse qui s'est
passé aujourd'hui demande une ouverture
de négociations pour des hausses des
salaires une prime qu'ovide et aussi des
embauches parce qu'on n'en parle pas
souvent mais à des tgv qui sont
aujourd'hui bondé et qui circulait qu'un
seul contrôleur à bord et c'est pas
sérieux au niveau de sécurité donc c'est
aussi une réponse pour les besoins des
usagers maxence fabriquez vous comprenez
quand on entend ça m'apporte nous
décrire cette situation huit ans de gel
des salaires mais monsieur porte sous
les 20 points pourtant c'est beaucoup
les cheminots ou vraiment rimé ils ont
travaillé durant la crise sanitaire
maintenant
on n'est pas spécialement favorable au
fait d' augmenter certaines catégories
de travailleurs et pas les autres c'est
à dire que les mesures pour le pouvoir
d'achat que propose eric zemmour ça a
vocation à toucher toute la population
française lorsqu'on parle de
défiscalisation de la participation
lorsqu'on parle de baisse de la csg pour
les salaires situés entre le smic et
2000 euros il ya une réelle volonté de
redonner du pouvoir d'achat aux français
ça ne touchera pas que les cheminots ça
touchera l'ensemble de la population sur
ce point de vue là c'est de notre côté
une réelle préoccupation après on
déplore forcément le fait que cette
grève interviennent à une période
pareille où les français ont quand même
trimé pendant toute l'année ils se
retrouvent dans une situation où les
périodes de noël sont quand même un des
rares moments il peut se retrouver en
famille pour souffler un coup et là ils
sont embêtés par des syndicalistes qui
défendent leurs intérêts corporatistes
absolument pas les intérêts des
cheminots thomas pense vous comprenez
cet argument parce que c'est vrai que
même gabriela talent cet après-midi
affirmé que les cheminots ont déjà eu
une prime de voir d'achat de 300 à 600
euros mise en place par la sncf
vrai ou faux est ce qu'il ya un cas
particulier cheminots ou tout simplement
ils ont peut-être un pouvoir de pression
qui est plus élevé que d'autres secteurs
parce qu un soignant qui se met en grève
on imagine voilà les conséquences sur la
santé mais enfin la saab est les
vacances certes on nous ressort toujours
l'argument de que ça dérange les usagers
quand on fait grève mais quelle que soit
la période à chaque fois on a cet
argument là mais moi j'ai envie de
renverser la charge de la responsabilité
si la direction de la sncf avait répondu
aux revendications des salariés du rail
sur les augmentations de salaires on
aurait pas de mobilisation sociale pour
les fêtes de noël parce qu'on fait pas
grève par plaisir parce que hein ça
coûte de l'argent et on sait que ça va
pénaliser des usagers mais c'est pas
simplement des intérêts corporatistes je
crois qu'aujourd'hui les cheminots qui
se mobilisent c'est aussi sur des
questions quand je rappelle qu'il faut
des contrôleurs à bord c'est des
questions de sécurité et ça concerne
aussi les gens qui prennent les traits
on a une dégradation avec l'ouverture à
la concurrence et la privatisation du
rail on pourra en parler mais tout ça
mis bout à bout mais qu'aujourd'hui on a
un service à bout de souffle mais c'est
pas le secteur le seul secteur public
qui souffre qui s'offre pardon vous avez
eu un reportage juste avant sur les
urgences à saint lys on voit que partout
le service public est attaqué par ce
gouvernement qu'il ya des restrictions
budgétaires des suppressions de postes
qui mettent en danger les populations et
qui dégradent les conditions de travail
des salariés donc c'est la mobilisation
est aujourd'hui nécessaire et moi je
leur apporte évidemment de tout mon
soutien mais qui sont impliqués
a sion effectivement des services
publics les cheminots le pouvoir
peut-être de nuisance entre guillemets
le pouvoir de faire bouger les choses
est ce que d'une certaine manière est
une forme de légitimité à l'utiliser
quand on est entre guillemets maltraité
la situation de base il faut quand même
la pause et c'est à dire que les cncf
est une entreprise qui a énormément de
difficultés financières qui avant la
reprise de sa dette de 50 5 milliards
par l'état à hauteur de 35 milliards
entre 2020 et 2022 permettez sur
l'entreprise qui est dans une situation
d'aléa moral c'est à dire qu'on a des
très mauvais choix stratégique
d'investissement qui ont été faits
pendant les trente quarante dernières
années
aujourd'hui tout le monde en paie les
pots cassés les usagers en premier chef
pour une raison assez simple c'est à
dire qu'aujourd'hui le gouvernement
gebre l'at-elle ça me fait un peu rire
ses réactions gabla ne doit pas prendre
le métro tous les jours c'est à dire
qu'il se rend bien compte que les
transports parisiens par exemple c'est
tout le temps bondé et dans les trains
là ça sera abondé à cause des cheminots
mais ceux qui en pâtissent le plus ce
sont les français et la france
périphérique qui est aujourd'hui sont
ceux qui doivent prendre le train pour
le ter ou transilien pour venir
travailler dans les grandes métropoles
qu'ils prennent pendant une heure une
heure et demie qui sont systématiquement
pénalisés par ça et qui aujourd'hui vont
se retrouver face à une grève qui encore
une fois peut porter des intérêts
légitimes n'y a pas de sujet là dessus
mais qui est menée par des syndicalistes
et particulièrement des cégétistes qui
aujourd'hui ne représente plus personne
il y avait 45 % de français syndiqués en
1950 aujourd'hui à -2 7 % sont des gens
qui ne représentent qu'eux mêmes et
qu'ils emmerdent les français comme et
georges pompidou l'emmerdement ce n'est
pas quelque chose qui est propre à
l'état et à l'inflation normative c'est
quelque chose qui peut aussi s'appliquer
aux corps intermédiaires qui eux
aujourd'hui jouissent d'un pouvoir ou
ceux la roche en tout cas de manière
complètement démesuré thomas porte à cet
argument une petite partie des
syndicaliste cégétiste qui représentent
qu'eux mêmes vous qui connaissez bien
cette entreprise est ce que c'est le cas
où est-ce que grande majorité des
salariés sont d'accord avec le déjà il
n'a pas fallu attendre longtemps à ce
débat extrêmement hâte insulter les
syndicats dont quoi on voit évidemment
qu'il y aura des qualités il se place
mais oui mais bon j'ai aucun souci a
qualifié avec des groupes d'extrême
droite et quand on voit les gens qui
l'entourent et connexes à mort peu de
sujets à débat et aujourd'hui les
syndicats la cgt notamment à la sncf et
la ratp sont confortés aux élections
professionnelles la cgt est la première
organisation représentative et ce
préavis de grève il n'est pas simplement
déposé par la cgt il est déposé par sud
rail et par l'unsa donc on voit qu'il ya
une unité syndicale sur ces questions là
parce qu'aujourd'hui les cheminotes et
cheminots qu'ils soient syndiqués
d'ailleurs ou pas sans mobiliser parce
que leurs conditions de travail se
dégradent et ils se mobilisent pour
augmenter les salaires et avoir des
conditions de travail qui permet
d'assurer la sécurité des usagers c'est
ça la réalité aussi non mais c'est ce
que vous dites c'est que tous les
syndicats sont mobilisés mais ça fait
douze personnes au total ça peut faire
tous les syndicats si vous voulez ils ne
représentent personne ne savait de
refermer sur les milieux anigo lui
connaît monsieur pour le coup moi je
passe ma vie à discuter avec des gens
qui bossent moi serait de l'immobilité
aussi donc je sais de quoi je parle je
suis vous êtes cheminots donc là dessus
je pense qu'on peut être sur un pied
d'égalité moi aujourd'hui vous me dites
que je suis d'extrême-droite définissez
l'extrême droite mais au logis fasciste
c'est ce que c'est aujourd'hui eric
zemmour d'attendre d'accord et vous
est-ce que vous avez déjà lu des livres
qui parlent du fascisme est ce qu'on
sait c'est que même si évidemment c'est
dingue que vous avez pas mis beaucoup de
temps non plus insulter les gens de
fasciste parce que oui vous êtes aussi
un observateur de l'extrême droite c'est
ça c'est assez dingue quand même de voir
accusés quand vous êtes
les six mois on la connaît monsieur
attaqué deux comme s'il vous plaît ou
d'un moment parce que si des décisions
de justice juste deux points le premier
point c'est que vous participer
aujourd'hui à des travaux des pseudos
travaux à l'observateur de l'extrême
droite qui vise à combattre les chimères
l'extrême droite je vous le dis vous
n'avez pas su répondre c'est une droite
qui est anti parlementariste et
anti-républicaine aujourd'hui elle
n'existe plus vous combattez des
chimères monsieur eric zemmour il combat
l'islamisme aujourd'hui et il est menacé
tous les jours
je reviens les gens proposition survient
c'est majeur je reviens maintenant j'y
viens je vais dire un deuxième point sur
le programme du ferroviaire le poids des
transports j'ai vu que vous étiez pour
le fait de remettre le fret ferroviaire
en avant nous sommes pour j'ai vu que
vous étiez pour le fait de revitaliser
les petites lignes nous sommes pour je
vous étiez pour le fait de favoriser
l'intermodalité notamment pour les
trajets domicile travail nous sommes
pour vous pensé exactement comme eric
zemmour monsieur vous voyez vous dit
qu'on n'a pas de programme vous dites
qu'on a pas d'idées mais en fait si
c'est juste vous qui vous drapez comme
ça dans votre défense de l'intérêt
général comme si vous étiez celui qui
défendrait la veuve et l'orphelin alors
que vous ne représentez que vous m'aimez
vous ne défendez personnes on va écouter
gabriela talent justement qui a réagi à
cette annonce de préavis de grève qu'ils
ont regretté ce choix écouté par parole
du gouvernement
je souhaite minoré au maximum l'impact
de cette grève pour les français ils ont
envie de pouvoir se retrouver en famille
à noël on n'a pas spécialement envie non
plus de se retrouver dans des trains
bondés et en période qu'ovide parce
qu'il ya moins de trains pour se
déplacer thomas forte attraction sur
gabriel attal vous allez être d'accord
de nouveau avec maxence fabriqué il doit
pas prendre souvent le métro parce que
c'est vrai qu'on n'attend pas les grèves
pour être un petit peu bombé dans le
métro parisien notamment chez les leçons
de gabriella talent sur le service
public et sur l'état du réseau il peut
se les garder parce que le gouvernement
fait partie de ceux qui ont cassé le
rail public aussi et notamment la
réforme des moniales mac ronde sur le
ferroviaire publique mais on n'a pas
attendu que les cheminots se mobilisent
contre les conditions salariales pour
que les transports sont bonnes et c'est
d'ailleurs ce qu'on dénonce depuis des
mois pour organiser ce qu'on appelle
avec jean luc mélenchon une société du
roulement qui permettent aux salariés de
prendre des transports qui soit pas
bondée alors qu'on sait que le virus
circule dans ces endroits là et quand
vous prenez le métro chaque matin à
paris vous rendez bien compte que c'est
hallucinant qu'on en pense les gens on
va regarder j'étais un petit coup d'oeil
à quelques réactions télégramme
voilà des téléspectateurs non c'est pas
ça voilà la question donc grogne sociale
ont-ils raison de faire la grève avant
les fêtes oui parce qu'ils ne sont pas
écoutés sans cela mais la gratuité des
voyages ou la garantie qu'il n'y aura
pas de contrôle de biais mettraient plus
la pression notamment vous êtes d'accord
avec cette proposition ça mettrait plus
la pression justement le contrôle des
billets michel qui nous dit aussi faire
la grève changer les choses ça serait
interdit de faire grève maxence briquets
non mais si si ces réactions la démontre
bien le réel malaise qu'il y a je pense
qu'aujourd'hui on peut quand même
légitimement s'interroger sur ce qu'ils
proposent est typiquement on parlait de
la gratuité des trajets aujourd'hui
lorsqu'on regarde le modèle de
financement des transports publics c'est
quelque chose qui est faisable c'est
déjà des transports qui sont largement
subventionnés tous tendance à augmenter
un métro à will we non mais la question
c'est pas l'augmentation du prix du
ticket qui à mon sens peut se justifier
c'est la part que paient réellement
l'usagé dans le prix final du trajet
c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui vous avez
les entreprises qui contribuent au
travers du versement mobilité vous avez
les collectivités locales qui abondent
dans le budget des autorités
organisatrices des mobilités vous avez
tous à tout un organisme public tout un
écosystème qui financent le système de
transport on a un bon système de
transport notamment de l'urbain
l'interurbain le système ferroviaire
tombe en désuétude faute
d'investissements à cause du tout tgv
qui a miné la dette de la sncf
aujourd'hui il ya trop peu
d'investissements il faut en refaire
pour le développement territorial pour
faire du développement économique de
l'est campagne donc on va dire
revitaliser les petites lignes favoriser
l'intermodalité et ça crée des emplois
tout ça vous avez dépôt des emplois de
l'industrie française vous avez la
possibilité d'embaucher des joueurs à la
sncf aussi lorsqu'il ya besoin de
contrôleurs dans les tgv ça c'est des
choses qu'on propose avec eric zemmour
pour 2022 donc vous êtes d'accord tu
m'apportes il reste une cadence et celui
du service public je suis pas sûr que
eric zemmour sur le premier garant et le
premier défenseur du service public j'ai
jamais vu prendre la défense de salariés
qui sont mobilisés pour la grève mais je
vais répondre ce qui a été dit sur le la
boucle télégramme si la greffe servent à
quelque chose on l'aurait interdite il y
avait quasiment 50% des français même
plus ce qu'ils étaient opposés à la
réforme des retraites à l'époque et on a
tous avaient soutenu les cheminots qui
étaient en première ligne pour s'opposer
à cette réforme là qui avait créé des
inégalités donc aujourd'hui ils sont
mobilisés pour défendre des conditions
de travail mais aussi défendre les
conditions d aujourd'hui quand vous
entendez gabriel aldié il faut minoré au
maximum l'impact de ces grèves
finalement quelle marge de manoeuvre
pour le gouvernement aujourd'hui pour le
coup gabriela talent je vais encore avec
vous on se passerait bien de ses leçons
c'est à dire que tous ces problèmes là
c'est lui qui les a causé c'est une
gestion très mauvaise de la crise
sanitaire par le gouvernement et
aujourd'hui on se retrouve avec le un
pompier pyromane qui
et devant le fait accompli on a
l'impression d'un enfant bea qui a pas
vraiment compris que toutes les
mauvaises routes blanches et noires
mauvaises décisions qu'il a prises à les
mener à cette situation là donc
forcément on déplore qu'on en soit
arrivé là que les français soient à la
fois matraqués par l'écrivain par la
gestion de la crise sanitaire et par les
grèves ça va être compliqué pour eux je
pense pour ceux qui vont voir se
déplacer en train pour noël et on espère
que ça se fera au mieux et en espérant
que le lac rond ne soit pas réélu en
2022 pour qu'enfin il ya du changement
dans ce domaine thomas porte vous dites
gel des salaires depuis huit ans alors
on sait qu' il n'y a pas eu que des
grèves pour la revalorisation des
salaires et beaucoup de grève sur les
retraites mais enfin ça veut dire que
quoi que la situation ne s'est pas du
tout améliorée au fil des années avec
toutes les greffes qui a eu du côté la
sncf s'est pas améliorée puisque les
salaires qui sont gelés sur huit années
consécutives ya peu aujourd'hui de
profession qui subit ça alors que
l'inflation je les rappelle dollar
augmente et que le coût de la vie et le
prix de l'énergie toutes ces
questions-là augmenter les cheminots
comme les autres ils subissent ces prix
là donc il ya eu mais les attaques elles
auraient été majeur sur la scène cfl ont
pas été simplement sur les salaires on a
une ouverture la concurrence qui va
entraîner une dégradation du réseau
comme ce qu'on a connus par exemple en
grande-bretagne on a cette ouverture à
la concurrence qui va dégrader le
service qui va remettre en cause les
conditions de travail et aujourd'hui si
on a des territoires entiers notamment
les gie légende qui avait dénoncé dans
leur mobilisation le droit à la mobilité
c'est qu'on a laissé des pans entiers du
territoire s'entraîne aujourd'hui et
sans aucun moyen de transport un jeu
rebondit juste sous ce qui a été dit
justement sur le fait que les cheminots
vu un gel de salaire depuis huit ans
typiquement ce que propose eric zemmour
sur encore une fois le fait de
défiscaliser la participation des
entreprises c'est quelque chose qui va
fortement augmenter leur pouvoir d'achat
à eux parce que la sncf est une
entreprise qui jusqu'à 2018 faisait des
bénéfices donc le fait de défiscaliser
la participation ça va inciter encore
une fois les cheminots a plus participé
à l'entreprise a plus impliqué dedans et
ça ne peut être que bénéfique pour la
sncf à terme merci beaucoup si tu
m'apportes merci a également fait
d'avoir été avec nous